the next question we're going to have a
look at is this mathematical induction
proof
proof for all uh n which is a subset or
is an element of
the positive integers by mathematical
induction
and then you've got this use of sigma
notation here which we then need to
unpack now
this question was done reasonably well
so i won't dwell too much on this
solution but let's have a look
at how the steps unfold here's uh where
we begin we've got our statement written
right here
that this submutation over here when
expanded out should
sum to give us this particular
expression on the right hand side
so as most uh proofs by induction begin
i want to take my base case i want to
evaluate that verify that it's
true i'll make my assumption and then
most of the work is going to be in the
proof step
as usual so noting that my uh
i'm saying that if we go back to the
question we have
that this is true for all um positive
integer values of n
i have to think carefully because we
know in extension 2 and this comes up
much bigger
later on in the test that extension 2
includes
the proofs by induction where the base
case is not always
n equals 1. but luckily for us in this
particular one
uh the first positive integer we can
think of is exactly n equals one so we
go ahead
test it out here's the left hand side me
putting in two
there's my uh r starts at one and then
you know goes up to one and then it
stops because i've already hit n equals
1 so this is the left-hand side
evaluated and then here comes the
right-hand side and it's a
straightforward substitution
n only appears a couple of times so
there is the substitution
and you end up with 3 on both sides
which you would hope is the case
here comes the assumption i've just gone
ahead and i've assumed it for
n equals k so that's why you can see the
k p here once
and then twice and then three times and
now
we then have to say well if we want to
use that assumption what are we trying
to prove
we're trying to prove the k plus 1 step
here so you can see
there is the first substitution the
second and then over here you just have
to be mindful of the fact that
really this is going to be 2 k plus
2 minus 1 that 2 k plus 2
comes from the 2 multiplied by k plus 1
and then that minus 1 there gives us 2 k
plus 1 as a whole of course you could
have put an extra step in there if you
wanted
all right uh what's the stat the the
sort of the strategy that i'm using here
well
um i start with the left hand side of my
k plus 1 step
and because the left hand side is
written in sigma notation it makes it
easy to kind of separate out the
assumption
from the part that's different and then
i need to work with the assumption make
a substitution
as you're about to see so what have i
done here as you can see on the right
hand side
i have taken this sigma notation which
goes previously from 1
up to k plus 1 and i've said well let's
look at the first k terms just leave
them within sigma notation
and then separate out that final term
the k plus one
term uh k plus first term no k plus one
term okay so there it is there k plus
one times three to the k plus one you
can see me
just substituting in k plus 1 into that
sigma notation
formula right there and the reason why
it's helpful to separate
separate out this sigma notation bit
here up to
n equals k is because that's what i had
in my assumption right so here it is
right there that's my assumption that
all of that the first k terms
equals this on the right hand side so
that's why you can see
right in here this is me using the
assumption
so there's the substitution which
replaces my sigma notation here
so this is handy because now i have a
whole bunch of
like terms which if i can expand this
out they're going to all
arrive and sort of cancel together or
interact so let's have a look
you can see at this point here all i'm
trying to do is expand these brackets on
the inside
and while i'm at it i can see i've got
three to the k
terms coming up here and here but i've
got a three to the k plus one
term over here on the right hand side so
what have i done i've taken the
three to the one that's been multiplied
through on this original term
and i've multiplied it through by the
the terms in the brackets so that's why
the k plus one
turns into a three k plus three uh at
this point down here i then notice
okay i've got a three quarters
factorized out here and i don't have it
here so
if i were to put it in place on both
spots
the reason why that's better than tray
you know say trying to expand out this
is because i think i have one eye on
what i'm proving
the algebra i'm manipulating right now
and i also have another eye on the
destination that i have in mind and if
you have a think back
this is the result we're trying to prove
it's got a three quarters out the front
so i'm not going to get rid of that so i
might as well
factorize out three quarters for
everything and so that's what i've done
right here
three clip 3k plus three is of course
three quarters of four k plus four so
that's me getting the
uh three quarters in position here and
here
once i've got it in both spots i then
factorize it out here
so that's where this comes from from
this term
and this one and what ensues is just me
writing out each of the terms inside the
brackets that have been factorized out
so
here comes the 1 3 to the k 2 k minus 3
to the k
and then you have to be careful here
because even though i've factorized out
the three quarters you still have this 3
to the k
hanging out on the end so that's why i
get 3 to the k 4k
and the 3 to the k i've got 4 of them
here okay now you can see by my
underlining i've got the zigzags and
then i've also got the double
lines i'm trying to collect like terms
at this point
so here are my terms which involved
the three to the k's and also k's
so they're going to go together and then
here are my three decays
with a constant term so in this case
i've got negative one of them and here
i've got
four of them so you can see that it
combines in let's see if i can
highlight this hopefully here are my
three the k terms by themselves
and they turn into this i've got 2k plus
4k equals 6k
and then in a similar way you can see
how these two terms combine
here it's 4 take away 1 which gives me
3.
all right now this is really great but i
do notice that if i again go back to
what i'm trying to prove
what i'm trying to prove here it's got
it doesn't have three to the k
terms it's got three to the k plus one
terms so in other words i've got to take
3 to the k and i've got to multiply it
by 3 and index laws will take care of
the rest so that's why you can see
for each of these two terms for this one
it's very easy there's just already a 3
there so it goes up into the index
for this one i pull the 3 out and that
leaves a 2k
behind so now i've also got this up in
the index
and at this point it is just a
straightforward factorization to say
i've got 2k of them here
i've got one of them there and here is
the required results so
you know if i were nice and neat i would
say it's true
by the principle of mathematical
induction
and as mentioned this was probably one
of the best done mathematical induction
questions because it was relatively
straightforward
if you were able to correctly interpret
the signal notation which most people
had no trouble with okay full stop
let's go back to the paper and have a
look at the next question
on the next page 5c says
prove that and we're back in complex
numbers land prove that the modulus of
z1z2 the product
or rather the modulus of a product
equals
module said one module said two prove
that the
modulus of a product equals the product
of the moduli for any complex number so
we're going to do that and then we're
going to prove
another result which we'll use in a
graph apparently
in part 3. so let's have a look at the
solutions
one at a time here is um
the what was i saying the modulus of the
product that we were looking at before
so i have been told if i come back to
the question i shouldn't get rid of it
so quickly
it says prove that this is true and it
then says kind of do it however you like
uh it doesn't specify any particular
process unlike part two
which says use the rectangular form of a
or the you know the cartesian form of a
complex number
so when i'm multiplying numbers together
the most concise way to do that
is using exponential form so you can see
me
specifying let's call z1 this and z2
that when you multiply them together
it's straightforward
index laws to then say okay i'm just
going to have my edi alpha my edi beta
they become e to the i alpha plus beta
and then my moduli at the front here
which i defined as
r1 and r2 they're just going to combine
there
now what's great about this line is if
you read it carefully you can see it's
asking for something very
straightforward
what is the distance from the origin of
this particular complex number well the
distance from the origin
doesn't have anything to do it's
independent of the argument
of that complex number it only has to do
with this numerical coefficient out the
front so
the modulus of this particular complex
number is just
that coefficient r1 r2 so i've got that
and i notice that r1 is the modulus of
z1
by definition and the same thing for r2
and z2 so that's
the modulus of z1 and the modulus of z2
done as required
now as i pointed out in part 2 it is
specified that you have to use
rectangular form
and really that's just to make things a
bit easier for you
because you could have done this in
exponential form but it will make the
transition to part three
ever so slightly trickier if i say z
equals x plus iy
that implies in rectangular form that
the conjugate of z is equal to x
minus i y i'm just flipping around the
sign on the imaginary term
now the reason why i bother to write
this is because you can see here this
result
depends on using z and then comparing it
to its conjugate and of course i have to
square as well right and then hopefully
where i end up with is four
i x y so let's see how that unfolds
you can see here here's my z minus z bar
and because i have defined
z and z bar in this way um all you get
left with
is like because the uh when you're
subtracting the two
real parts were identical so they cancel
each other out so
that's great i just get left with the
imaginary bits 2 iy
and the opposite is true when i'm adding
the complex conjugates when i've got z
plus z bar you can see the i y and the
minus iy
they just cancel and that's what leaves
me with 2x so then you multiply through
and you get 4ixy as needed
so then we come to part three and i hope
as you looked at the question you saw
how you were going to need to use parts
one and two
part two is easy or more obvious rather
i should say to use
you can see over here on the left hand
side of what we're asked to graph here
there's that same z-squared minus z-bar
squared
that we used in part two or rather that
we proved a result for in part two
so this is clearly implying that if i if
i take this and
substitute it for what's on the right
hand side for ixy
that's going to make this easier which
indeed it does so let's have a look at
how this pans out
here is me substituting in for ixy and i
got that from part 2.
it's equal to 16. i notice that that 4
because it's a positive coefficient i
can just divide everything through by 4
which
is what gives me the next line from the
modulus of ixy
i now use part 1. part 1 told me that if
i've got some modulus of a product
i can just break up that product into
however many pieces that i want and then
take the moduli
independently and so that's what i'm
doing here you could you can see excuse
me
i pulled out i which is its own complex
number and
x y which is also some complex number
who knows what it is
and because i've got the product
of these two moduli equal to the modulus
of the product
i can very easily determine oh wait a
second the
modulus of i is just 1 because if you
think of where i
is here's my quick and dirty argon
diagram it's just
one unit above the origin on the complex
planes so that is why its modulus is 1.
once i have that fact established i'm
just getting the absolute value of x y
being equal to 4. now you need to think
about this carefully
when you're thinking about moduli and
absolute value what that essentially
means is i want all the things
that when i just look at their raw
magnitude i don't worry about direction
anymore
when i think about their magnitude or
their distance from the origin i should
get four
well there's exactly two real numbers
that do that and i'm thinking about real
numbers because i've got x
and y both of which are have to be real
by definition
x and y can be either positive 4 or
negative 4.
both of those numbers both of those
numbers on the real
number line are exactly 4 units away
from the origin so they both
satisfy both these numbers satisfy this
equation
once you've got the plus or minus 4
there it's just a matter of dividing
through by x
and we get a familiar hyperbola that we
know how to graph except
there's two of them right you can see
here
let's highlight it this would be the 4
over x part we're pretty used to that
hyperbola so i'll just
label it as such 4 over x and then
secondly you also have this
reflected one this here is a separate
hyperbola it's y equals negative 4 over
x you can see i've just turned it
upside down it was a very common error
for students to
miss the fact that there were more
branches than you would normally get for
a hyperbola
so just before i leave off this question
it is worth pointing out that
missing the absolute value and the fact
you get both the plus and the minus that
was one major factor
also not putting in your asymptotes that
was just kind of sloppy so it was very
disappointing to see
asymptotic behavior but no asymptotes
actually you know drawn in and labeled
on the graph
and then lastly as a very very small
point but it is
i think if you know i'm trying to show
you a perfect specimen solution is what
we call it
this graph here and all of its branches
here here here and here
it could just as easily have been plus
or minus 1 over
x or plus or minus 5 over x or plus or
minus 500
over x they all look like this the only
difference
is the scale so that's why i've put a
point for scale or some people like to
call it a locking point
now that i have placed this on this
first branch
only y equals 4 over x can satisfy that
this can't be y equals
5 over x anymore because um the point 2
plus 2 i
wouldn't be on there and that's how you
do this graph not complicated
to draw but you had to think about how
to use all of your earlier parts which
was a consistent issue throughout
this exam there were lots of multi-part
questions and better responses stronger
responses always
kept in mind their previous results and
also
i quoted them made them really clear
right you can see here
i state very explicitly there's part two
that's where i use it when i said oh
i'm substituting from here to here
here's part one when i said i broke
apart this
modulus of a product into the product of
the moduli tell me where that's coming
from
that's a really good practice to clearly
communicate your mathematical working